on jouait donc ce qui est devenu les
bronzés c'était amour coquillages et
crustacés jeu jouer le même rôle dans le
film michelle blanc quel privilège de
parler la troupe du splendid a été
formée en 1974 après 50 ans de carrière
qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous ce
césar anniversaire vous savez ça fait
toujours
c'est très étonnant parce qu'on pourrait
se dire que c'est comme une récompense
d'anciens combattants mais moi je ne le
feront pas comme ça je me dis simplement
que ce qui est assez miraculeux c'est
que la période du splendid pourrait être
totalement oublié par le public
en tout cas le public français quelques
quarante ans après avoir tourné les
bronzés c'est très étrange s'est
prestement comme sensation on ne
s'attendait pas à ça il ya 40 ans si
vous voulez que je vous parle
franchement on dit que le club c'est la
mort du couple alors je suis célibataire
le film les bronzés a vraiment été un
point tournant pour la troupe du
splendid
vous y incarnez là bas jean claude dusse
vraiment vers la gare avec le recul et
l'expérience
comment expliquez vous le succès d'un
tel fait mais je voudrais pas dire que
peut-être que beaucoup de gens se sont
reconnus enfin beaucoup d'hommes se sont
reconnus dans ce type qui n'a pas de
chance avec hesham j'espère que non pas
trop mais c'est vrai que j'ai cherché
mois mme on avait le sujet le sujet
c'était 17 et le club méditerranée tel
qu'il était à l'époque ça a beaucoup
changé maintenant et tant mieux
d'ailleurs pas ce que c'était on voit
que ça n'était pas les rapports
hommes-femmes noté le pape tout temps de
la plus grande délicatesse dans le film
mais c'était un peu comme ça dans la vie
aussi c'est pour ça qu'on a mis dans le
film et puis il ya eu c'est surtout les
dialogues qui ont marqué les gens parce
que c'est sorti sur le dialogue qu'on
que les gens ont ri qui maintenant qu'il
m'apostrophe dans la rue en disant alors
tu vas conclure où on sait jamais sur un
malentendu
voilà tout ça en me leur sort encore
maintenant 40 ans après le très bon ami
à nous ils sont allés en sang venus en
dalles et alors on s'est dit pourquoi
pas mais j'ai fait une connerie je suis
venu avec la femme
les rapports hommes-femmes sont pas
toujours et les gars dans le film les
bronzés fanon est ce que je peux finir
billets viennent apparemment les gens
savent leur situer dans son contexte et
puis surtout ça se passait comme ça dans
l'endroit que l'on montre donc et
s'était passé pas un film manifeste
dix ans c'est une bonne manière de se
comporter entre mes femmes pas du tout
si ou là vous êtes dans le lubéron je
suis car le bouquet vous reconnaissez
comment vous êtes à la comparer à tant d
auto rien au total vous avez joué dans
plus de 60 films
vous avez souvent joué des personnages
timide hypocondriaque
toujours dans la comédie j'ai un peu
l'impression que c'est votre expérience
en tant qu'enfant tu rejoins le comédien
votre vie adulte et vous avez mélanger
tout ça pour la porter à l'écran ça
c'est fort possible toute façon je suis
hypocondriaque là ça confirme maintenant
l'enfant l'enfant était assez joyeux moi
je m'amuse et bien j'ai pas eu je parle
de la petite enfance
l'adolescence est toujours une période
difficile dans tout le monde et moi je
laisse mal vécue parce que parce que je
je commençais à perdre messieurs 14 ans
et donc c'est très inquiétant
on se dit je vais être chauve à 18 en
face était c'était une période que je ne
n'ai pas envie de revenir mais je ne
regrette pas l quelle gueule mais ça
peut inventer caoutchouc du fanal eagle
je sais bien j'en ai pas une c'est pas
tous les jours ma portée je pense que la
longévité de votre carrière est en
partie dû à votre goût du risque
ah je pense justement tenue de soirée
qui vous a valu un prix à cannes ou chez
blast que se mettre en danger pour vous
un mot d'ordre
alors il ya deux réactions possibles
quand on lit à ses narines et où vous le
trouvez franchement mauvais ou le
personnage vous intéresse pas mais
si le scénario est un bon scénario un
des éléments qui me décide à le faire
c'est ce qui me fait peur
si j'ai peur de pas y arriver et là je
me dis ah bah ça veut dire qu'il ya un
vrai enjeu
ça veut dire que tu l'as pas fait
cinquante fois ça veut dire qu'il ya un
enjeu exceptions sacristie
donc si vous reconnaissez quand même
c'est qui ce qui ce qui jean claude
dusse michel blanc je vous que la boucle
et je veux terminer avec le splendide
vous avez déjà dit que les bronzés 3 et
qu'un échec donc pas question d'avoir un
bronzé quatre mais ce que veulent moi
web pour vous mais ce que vous avez
d'autres projets avec la troupe du
splendid n'a pas pour l'instant mais
vous allez le problème d'avoir un un
projet avec l'ensemble de la troupe
c'est que c'est koné 6 il faut trouver
une histoire qui comporte six rôles
aussi intéressants les uns que les
autres et ça je vous assure que c'est un
cahier des charges qui est très très dur
à tenir
michel blanc je vous donne l'accolade de
façon virtuelle merci beaucoup c'est
très gentil puis c'est la seule manière
dont on puisse le faire maintenant donc
je le fais aussi merci